Doesn't ever wake you  in the middle of the night...
...The feeling that some day they'll pass that foolish law?
Is it true? they can cure us?
There are mutants so powerful, that they can enter out minds...
...And control our toughts
Thaking away our God given free will
The truth is
That mutants are very real
And they are among us
We must know...
...Who they are...
...And above all we must know...
What they can do?
Don't give up on them Erik
What you'll have me do Charles?
I've heard those arguments before
It was a long time ago
Mankind has evolved since then
Yes, into us
Peace was never an option
Charles!
War is still coming Charles
and I intend to fight it
The real enemy is out there
You have no idea what I have done
I know that you took the things that meant the most to me
Well maybe you should have fought harder for them
You would die for them?
Not for them...
...For you!
We need you to hope again
The world needs the X-Men
Not all of us can control our powers
Then don't!
I have never felt power like this before
Don't let it control you
It's all of us against a god
You are not students anymore...
You're X-Men!